Before we talk about the abstractions in
an operating system for managing the processor and
memory, I want to throw another fun quiz at
you. Now in this quiz, I'm going to ask
you the following question. The computer, regardless of
which platform you're using, seemingly runs several programs
in parallel. You may have an email program
running, a browser you may have music playing,
maybe you're watching a video clip and so
on, but supposed it is, only one CPU inside.
Let's assume, that your computer system has exactly
one CPU inside. How is it possible that it
is running several programs in parallel? I'm going to
give you multiple choices. The first choice is, even
though there is only one CPU, there are
multiple cores within the CPU, and there's one core
for each of the applications that you're running,
and that's how we're able to run multiple applications
in parallel. So that's your first choice. The second
choice is, I'm trying to trick you, that this
is a trick question, actually there's only one
app that is running at a time and the
premise of the question itself is wrong. So that's
your second choice. The third choice says that there's
only one CPU, there are multiple applications,
but these applications share the CPU through
the operating system so that for different
time units, different applications are running on
the CPU. So, for instance, in time unit t1 application one is running, time unit
t2 application two is running, and so on. And this is what is
making it appear as though there are several programs running on the CPU
simultaneously. What is going on is that the operating system is multiplexing
the CPU among these applications. So these are the choices I'm giving you,
and I want you to pick what you think is the right choice.